this is the moment that Gemma Mitchell
knew her time was up
all right Gemma at this moment I'm
resting on the suspicion of murder weeks
before she had killed and then
decapitated her so-called
friendly given the evidence okay her
victim Deborah Chong was described as
vulnerable but generous offering to low
Mitchell 200 000 pounds towards home
renovations but days before her Murder
She had changed her mind and Mitchell
took matters into her own hands
here she was captured on CCTV walking
towards Deborah's home with a suitcase
hours later she was spotted again this
time the cashier's dragon is visibly
heavier because it now contains the body
of Miss Chong
it would take two weeks before she would
move the corpse from her home first
decapitating it before driving 200 miles
to Devon where it was finally dumped
leaving it for a family to find go ahead
call to watch emergency
and I just found a body
however the head wouldn't be recovered
until days later why is that Gemma
and questions still remain unanswered as
Mitchell refused to cooperate
no comments
Mitchell was the first woman in England
to be handed a life sentence live on TV
where she was told she would serve a
minimum of 34 years in prison the
enormity of your crime
is profoundly shocking
even more so given your apparent
religious devotion
as well as the fact that Deborah Chong
was a good friend to you and had shown
you great kindness
outside Court Mitchell's mum refused to
accept her daughter's guilt she is
innocent and I know that and I'm going
to go to the top I'm not accepting this
but the jury is guilty verdict was
helped by documents found in Mitchell's
property naming herself and her mum as
beneficiaries of Miss Chung's entire
estate a crime clearly committed for
financial gain Shimon Freeman Powell Sky
News